en plaidant coupable derek chauvine
s'est invitée à un nouveau procès
initialement prévu au mois de janvier
par la justice fédérale américaine un
accord de plaider coupable avait été
convenu avec les procureurs et pendant
l'audience d'eric chauvine s'est
contenté d'acquiescer suite aux
déclarations du juge alors concrètement
l'ancien policier à a plaidé coupable
pour les faits de violation des droits
constitutionnels de georges floyd
notamment en le privant de son droit de
ne pas être victime d'un usage
disproportionné de la force dans le
cadre de cet accord les procureurs ont
requis une peine de 300 mois de prison
c'est à dire 25 ans ce qui rallongerait
de deux ans et demi la peine déjà
prononcée contre derek chauvine cet été
par un tribunal de l'état du minnesota
le fait que derek sherwin plaide
coupable est assez surprenant puisqu'il
avait plaidé l' inverse au mois de
septembre dernier tout comme ses trois
collègues qui sont eux aussi impliqués
par cette procédure à fédéral eux sont
poursuivis notamment pour ne pas avoir
empêché la dérive chauvine de faire un
usage disproportionné de la force ou
encore pour ne pas avoir à porter dead
médical hadjres floyd en réaction à
l'audition de derek chauvine qui
n'étaient pas filmés la famille de
l'afro-américain tués au mois de mai
2020 a salué je cite un beau jour pour
la justice